[Music]
as the monsoon rains intensify across
Bangladesh along with high humidity and
heat there are fears that Dengue Fever
outbreak will get worse
nazmaster had to rush her 11 year old
son to a private hospital because she
couldn't find any accommodation in a
government-run hospital a medical
emergency increasingly becoming common
across the country
within a day we rushed him to the
hospital after he was going into shock
his blood platelet count dropped to a
critical point and he had very low blood
pressure he is now recovering very
slowly
but many here can afford to take their
children to a private Hospital
the woman should take steps to eradicate
mosquitoes it's just not adequate and
City corporations should take more steps
to keep things more hygienic and Keen
I had to break my savings bond to be the
hospital expense the World Health
Organization is calling on Bangladesh to
control its mosquito population and
minimize people's exposure to the
mosquito-borne diseases
the increase in Dengue cases is causing
alarm among people in Dhaka and other
places and doctors in many hospitals are
struggling to cope with the rising
number of patients
Monir Hussein is a physician who says
this outbreak is unlike his saying
before there's now an increasing number
of children who are getting admitted to
hospitals with fluid buildup in their
vital organs causing refractory shock
and eventual death
this time the Dengue situation is very
critical unlike before both the doctors
and patients are facing much more
challenging clinical issues compared to
previous years the World Health
Organization is also warning cases of
dengue fever worldwide could reach
record highs this year partly due to
global warming and that half of the
world population is now at risk of
Contracting Dengue in Bangladesh experts
say erratic weather condition and poor
drainage and sanitation are partly to
blame for the rise in Dengue and have
urged the government for more
coordinated and efficient response to
deal with the crisis San Andreas Dhaka
foreign